[Music]
on this tuesday night a revolt within
the conservative party federal leader
aaron o'toole vows to put up a fight as
he faces a vote on his future there's
only so long that the party can tolerate
this kind of dissent internally can he
survive and what does the rift mean for
the party
the rcmp moves in to clear a border
blockade in alberta but at the end of
the day that border's got to get open
the mounting frustration over the
trucker-led protests clogging the
nation's capital plus as the omicron
wave shows signs of cresting in the east
hospitals in western canada are still
feeling the crush
and the final act for a football
superstar
after seven super bowl titles tom brady
leaves the field his legacy and next
chapter
[Music]
global national with donna
friesen good evening and thanks for
joining us the internal rift within the
federal conservative party is spilling
out into the open leader aaron o'toole
is facing a caucus revolt
at the same time as some of the
protesters in ottawa now into their
fourth day of disrupting the downtown
core are focusing their sights on prime
minister justin trudeau it is actually
aaron o'toole's future that is now on
the line and it is happening fast mps
will vote tomorrow by secret ballot
during the conservative caucus meeting
o'toole says the party is at a
crossroads and must choose either an
angry negative extreme path or a more
moderate one our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson has our top story
tonight
the revolt against aaron o'toole is
widespread and very public i think the
leader's position is untenable right now
the fact is that
the process has been initiated
and when 35 members of caucus
call on
the leader
to effectively resign
then i think that perhaps that's the
leader has some thinking to do
nearly one-third of the conservative
caucus have signed a letter rising up
against their leader o'toole says he
will stand and fight to stay in power
tweeting i'm not going anywhere and i'm
not turning back canada needs us to be
united and serious it's time for a
reckoning to settle this in caucus right
here right now once and for all anger
versus optimism
even if o'toole wins staying on after
losing confidence of so much of caucus
would be difficult i think he will go
down at the end of the day because
there's only so long that the party can
tolerate this kind of dissent internally
he's been trying to stamp it out since
the election and it hasn't worked the
september election loss is a key
irritant where o'toole swung to the
center and flip-flopped on major
policies those who want o'toole out say
he is unprincipled and doesn't listen to
caucus they're angry about his policies
on climate change and gun control but
deny ideological differences are their
bottom line
o'toole's supporters characterized the
battle as a war for the soul of the
conservative party
modern and electable or outdated and
fringe but that doesn't explain
o'toole's low polling numbers and
difficulty fundraising that's i think
vital michelle rempel garner backs
o'toole and says another leadership
campaign is a distraction a month months
long leadership process right now
i mean that's time not spent holding
justin trudeau to account conservative
strategist tasha kiradin says internal
divides over the trucker protest in
ottawa turned simmering descent into an
explosive leadership challenge i think
that what happened on the weekend
has shown that there is a serious schism
within the party that probably can't be
healed tonight sources tell global news
aaron o'toole is calling members a
caucus opening the door to changing his
policies again if he can stay on as
leader they say that's too little too
late and that it won't address the main
issue for them trust
donna
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks
and this is southern alberta the rcmp
are trying to clear a blockade at a busy
border crossing into the u.s police
announced earlier today that they
decided that blockade by protesters
angry about vaccine mandates and public
health restrictions is no longer lawful
and they moved in the protest by
truckers farmers and others have stopped
the flow of goods and people across the
border for four days and trapped some
truckers who don't support it our
heather urix west has been at the scene
all day heather alberta's premier just
spoke to the media he again called the
protest unacceptable what else did he
say
well donna he began by expressing some
support for those who were participating
in lawful protests against vaccine
mandates for for truckers he said that
he in his recent trip to washington that
he was looking for allies to find an
exemption for unvaccinated cross-border
truckers who didn't
so they shouldn't have to quarantine but
he went on to call this blockade illegal
and unacceptable he urged protesters
to to quit and he also
called for calm
after
several disturbing reports of violence
involving protesters within the last
couple of hours
i've also received reports
in the last hour of people allied with
the protesters assaulting rcmp officers
including in one instance trying to ram
members of the rcmp
later leading to a collision with a
civilian vehicle this kind of conduct is
totally unacceptable
heather the blockade is still in place
though the rcmp still there any sign of
a resolution soon
no in fact we have about a hundred uh
vehicles still blockading the road and
uh from what we can see it seems as
though our cmp have uh pulled pulled
back we're not seeing the helicopter
circling um we're not seeing
the same kind of presence that we were
seeing a couple of hours ago but we have
seen new
police enforcements arrive just a short
time ago we saw
five police cars from the lethbridge
police service arrive
more vehicles from canadian border
services agency so while we don't have
an official update on the rcmp's plans
this evening
this is still a very fluid situation and
one that we will of course be continuing
to watch in the hours and days ahead
all right heather urich's west in coots
alberta thanks
meanwhile in ottawa businesses and
people who live downtown are still
dealing with the honking and the trucks
and the disruption of that ongoing
protest over vaccine mandates and public
health restrictions abigail beeman has
been speaking with people around
parliament hill today where it appears
there is also no resolution in sight
a breakfast barbecue in the middle of
what's normally a busy downtown street
now full of parked vehicles these
truckers say they've been so overrun
with donations they're feeding people in
the neighborhood too we came here
to be
respectful of the people that live in
the city but still make our cause heard
but some fed up residents feel all this
has become more occupation than protest
alan gimmel took a sandwich calling it
repayment for his lack of sleep now we
hear these horns going all night long
it's driving us crazy i haven't slept in
three days we're trying to get to campus
but all of the
bus routes to campus are closed it's a
little bit intimidating coming into work
which i have to do every day
[Music]
[Applause]
they're in what i would call the splash
zone i feel bad for them
and
but
when you want to change something in
history there's always going to be some
uncomfortableness involved in that there
are fewer vehicles but it's still
complete gridlock on a number of
downtown ottawa streets like this one
and a number of businesses and amenities
remain closed including a major downtown
mall two child care centers a
vaccination clinic and a number of
businesses
it's like we're being held hostage down
here the metropolitan brasserie shut its
doors after it became clear delivery
drivers couldn't get through we've heard
the message and
now you're hurting our businesses and we
really would just ask that they leave
peacefully and let our city get back to
business because you're really just
ruining people
the noise pollution itself the constant
honking you know it seems as like a
like a real scare tactic the protest
prompted ellie charters to start a
grassroots walking buddy program for
downtown residents operating through
twitter dms it doesn't seem to me as
though any concrete actions to make
people feel safe is happening on the
part of the police or the mayor many
want police to start ticketing and
towing but that's not happening yet and
an end game isn't clear we're not going
anywhere we've lost our jobs a lot of us
some of us have lost our houses
some of us will lose our houses with
some residents calling for more action
there were no updates from police today
one is scheduled for wednesday there is
now a tip line to report hate incidents
or anything criminal related to these
protests but police haven't said how
many calls they've yet received donna
abigail beeman in a still noisy downtown
ottawa thanks
to the pandemic now and a major reversal
from quebec premier francois lago he is
scrapping plans to impose a tax on the
unvaccinated because he says he's seeing
growing discontent about it
i understand that this divides quebecers
and right now
we need to build bridges to listen to
each other
my role the proposed tax was initially
billed as a way to help reduce the
burden of unvaccinated patients on
quebec's hospitals lago repeated today
that the unvaccinated are much more
likely to end up in the hospital with
covid19 he says the province plans to
use other ways to encourage people to
get the shot
new modeling out of ontario suggests the
omicron wave has plateaued in that
province as in other provinces though
hospitalizations which are a lagging
indicator remain a concern jamie morocco
looks at what could happen as public
health restrictions begin to ease
dr laura harlock is coming off a 10-day
stretch inside the icu at this toronto
hospital where one-third of its 37 beds
with ventilators are occupied by covid
patients we're still getting covered
admissions or people with covet who need
our help
it's slowing in terms of the rate a
little bit the latest hospitalization
numbers from ontario and quebec are
trending downward but as the provinces
reopened there's concern the dip may not
last we could face potentially in march
a peak which is even higher that's what
we need to avoid that's not what anyone
wants to hear with frustrations growing
over covered restrictions and lockdowns
as we watch other countries like the uk
and denmark open up you can look at what
other countries are doing but please
don't just follow blindly what every
other country is doing although the
majority almost 78 percent of canadians
are fully vaccinated booster uptake is
still less than half
and our health care systems continue to
struggle hospitals and care clinics are
extremely short staffed and workers are
exhausted from yet another wave and in
the west hospitalizations are still
rising manitoba and bc with record
numbers this week we can't look at it
linearly and we have to look at it all
together what's happening we have
multiple indicators that the peak virus
load was
earlier in january
we know that hospitalizations follow
that health officials also warn omicron
won't likely be the end of kovitt harluk
knows it's almost a certainty more
variants will emerge and worries we
continue to be reactive versus proactive
repeating the same mistakes over and
over again is not going to get us
anywhere
wondering how critical care units will
fare
if they have to weather yet another wave
jamie morocco global news toronto
now to some breaking news out of the u.s
pfizer and biontech are seeking
emergency use authorization of the
covid19 vaccine for children under age
five the companies say they have
submitted data for a two dose vaccine
for children six months to four years
old that's despite disappoint
disappointing clinical trial results
that showed a lower immune response in
some younger age groups the companies
say they are researching whether three
doses will work health canada says it
has not yet received an application from
pfizer for children under age five
though it's expected in the coming weeks
allegations from russia over the crisis
in ukraine coming up vladimir putin
accuses the u.s of trying to draw his
country into war
[Music]
there is a new warning from the canadian
government about travel to ukraine it
says security conditions are
unpredictable and could deteriorate
without notice canadians are asked to
avoid all travel to ukraine anyone
already there is being urged to leave
while commercial means are available
hopes for a diplomatic solution are
fading in his first significant comments
in weeks russian president vladimir
putin said today he's not backing down
and he's accusing the u.s of trying to
lure russia into war jackson proskow
reports
the russian buildup now extends to
belarus where thousands of troops are
planning snap exercises on ukraine's
northern border
in moscow president vladimir putin
accused the u.s of trying to draw russia
into armed conflict warning american
attempts at diplomacy outlined in a
letter last week were badly off course
fundamental russian concerns were
ignored he said
putin's demands include rolling back the
size of nato and banning ukraine from
joining the alliance the west isn't
budging on either point
in kiev where the british prime minister
paid a visit there are signs the
ukrainian government now views the
russian threat with the same alarm as
the west this wouldn't be a war between
ukraine and russia warned ukrainian
president zelinski this would be a
full-scale war in europe
a further
russian
invasion
of ukraine
would be a political disaster a
humanitarian disaster ukraine the uk and
poland are now preparing to form their
own trilateral alliance at nato
headquarters canada's defense minister
echoed the western view that what
happens next is up to putin russia has
an important
choice to make
it can choose to negotiate with a view
to de-escalation
or it can face
harsh economic sanctions despite all
those worrying signs putin did leave the
door open to more dialogue suggesting a
deal may be reached eventually the u.s
is still waiting on a formal russian
response to its written proposals so far
there's no sign there will be enough
there to end the tense stare down over
ukraine
jackson prosco global news washington
stuck in another crisis ahead the afghan
family bound for canada stranded in
ukraine
[Music]
as tensions grow in ukraine one family
from afghanistan is facing an especially
uncertain future there in the fall we
introduced you to javid hakmal a former
canadian forces interpreter after the
taliban takeover his family fled to
ukraine in hopes of coming to canada but
their asylum claim still hasn't been
approved and now with embassy staff
leaving ukraine they're in limbo once
again
crystal gomencing reports
javir
came to ukraine six months ago fleeing
the taliban with his family he never
dreamed he'd still be here now i'm
really shocked the worst thing is you
know i have a pregnant woman i'm just
surprised i'm just shocked about this
issue that what will i do with this
woman if the war is started stuck in a
foreign country with an expectant wife
no language skills no money and no
support
hakmal and his 11 family members landed
in kiev as a transit stop they hoped on
their way to canada the former canadian
forces interpreter was rescued from
kabul after the taliban took over his
connection to canada put his life at
risk and his families
we met the huck malls in october when
their temporary visas expired they'd
spent nearly every hour of every day in
their hotel which is paid for by the
globe and mail
it helped him and another afghan
interpreter who worked for the paper to
safety
the kids are bigger now and they're
happy to see new faces and play
their dad however says he isn't giving
them the life they deserve
this was not his plan for them if by
chance the prime minister or the
immigration minister or the defense
minister sees this
what do you want to say to them i will
tell them i am a human like you too you
put me in there you don't care about me
and the time you needed me you used me
anger born out of pain and fear his
calls go on returned his questions
unanswered like thousands of others he
says he's told only his application is
being processed we reached out to
multiple government departments for
comment ircc sent a statement saying it
is doing the utmost to process cases
there is nothing else for me nothing no
hope is left for me his family back in
afghanistan asks about the war in
ukraine he lies and says there are no
worries no risks
but privately he fears what could happen
next
crystal gamson global news
keith
the end of an era next tom brady is
finally leaving the field
well there are football stars and then
there's tom brady over 22 years of
quarterbacking he has racked up a record
seven super bowl wins and even if you're
not a football fan you've no doubt heard
about him today at age 44 brady
announced he is retiring eric sorenson
looks at his almost mythical and
complicated stature as a sports star
he was an unheralded sixth round draft
pick and yet tom brady all but put to
rest any debate over who's the greatest
quarterback of all time he's the best of
all time
no one touches him hall of fame best of
all time nothing else would be said he
was cool under pressure orchestrated
sensational comebacks and was even lucky
at times though was never comfortable
talking about his legacy i'm not good
with you know things like that so i i um
i mean i feel like i've done a great job
to maximize
what my potential was brady set
touchdown and passing records won an
unprecedented seven super bowls and was
the mvp in five of them i think some
spaceship dropped tom brady off on this
planet a lot of years ago he's a freak
it's as simple as that and always a joy
to watch in a brutal sport that shortens
most careers to an average of three and
a half years brady excelled for 22
seasons he should be one of the most
beloved athletes but it's more
complicated than that i would never do
anything to break the rules
his new england patriots were once
caught spying on another team brady was
once suspended after footballs were
deflated for him by a team manager some
didn't like his politics a fan of donald
trump and when teammates took a knee to
protest racial injustice brady did not
for many a polarizing figure whether you
love him or whether you hate them you
know you have to respect them because
the stats and the accolades just speak
for themselves i hate tom brady so much
but brady learned to laugh at being
hated
but i hope they break his leg
but critics could not deny his enduring
talent in a statement he called his
career a thrilling ride and far beyond
my imagination adding that now it's best
i leave the field to the next generation
tom brady will be a tough act to follow
eric sorensen global news
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is grand prai nova scotia there
are beautiful spots all over this
country please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]